good afternoon I have today left
hospital after a week in which the NHS
has saved my life no question it's hard
to find words to express my debt but
before I come to that I want to thank
everyone in the entire UK for the effort
and the sacrifice you have made and are
making when the Sun is out and the kids
are at home when the whole natural world
seems that its loveliest and the
outdoors is so inviting I can only
imagine how tough it has been to follow
the rules on social distancing I thank
you
but there's so many millions and
millions of people across this country
have been doing the right thing
millions going through the hardship of
self-isolation faithfully patiently and
with thought and care for others as well
as for themselves I want you to know
that this Easter Sunday I do believe
that your efforts are worth it and our
daily proving their worth because
although we mourn everyday those who are
taken from us in such numbers and though
the struggle is by no means over
we are now making progress in this
incredible national battle against
coronavirus fight we never picked
against an enemy we still don't entirely
understand we're making progress in this
national battle because the British
public formed a human shield around this
country's greatest national asset our
National Health Service we understood
and we decided that if together we could
keep our NHS safe if we could stop our
NHS from being overwhelmed then we could
not be beaten and this country would
rise together and overcome this
challenge as we have overcome so many
challenges in the past in the last seven
days I have of course seen the pressure
that the NHS is under
I've seen the personal courage not just
of the doctors and nurses but of
everyone the cleaners the cooks the
health care workers of every description
physios radiographers pharmacists who've
kept coming to work kept putting
themselves in harm's way
kept risking this deadly virus it is
thanks to that courage that devotion
that duty and that love that our NHS has
been unbeatable British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson has been discharged from
hospital after being treated for cope it
19 Johnson was admitted a week ago and
spent three days in intensive care he's
released from st. Thomas's Hospital in
London comes as the UK death toll from
coronavirus tops 10,000 one of the
highest in the world
Johnson's government has come under fire
over a lack of personal protective
equipment for frontline workers in
hospitals well for more I'm joined by
Charlotte Potts in London Charlotte p.m.
Boris Johnson ins now been discharged
from hospital what more do we know him
well the Prime Minister has left to the
Prime Minister's country estate checkers
to continue his recovery there and it's
certainly been a wake-up call for Boris
Johnson and for the country for the
British people it showed that the virus
doesn't discriminate that it doesn't
stop at Downing Street and for Boris
Johnson well he was very let's say
careless in the beginning of the crisis
and did not jump immediately to action
and now he has experienced what it means
firsthand by spending a week at the
hospital and you mentioned three three
days in intensive care
now Downing Street saying his recovery
might take a while we're even hearing
that he would not be back in charge for
several weeks and the UK death toll
meanwhile has now topped 10,000 with the
government facing pretty intense
criticism over its handling of the
crisis is there the feeling in the UK
that some of those deaths were indeed
preventable
yes for sure over the weekend we saw the
highest daily death toll in Europe over
900 deaths per day and that continues
that number continues to rise doctors
and nurses are saying they don't have
enough protective gear to protect
themselves one in three surgeons even
saying that they can't operate because
they don't have that proper gear at the
same time doctors and nurses are dying
nearly 20 nhf staff so far have died and
there is also a serious lack of testing
only the very severe cases at the moment
are tested at the hospital so there is
no tracking virtually happening in the
unrecorded number of cases of
coronavirus here in the UK is incredibly
high and this all as the peak is about
to be reached so really a crisis that
could have been prepared for much
earlier reporting from London chela
Potts thank you now let's get you caught
up to date on the corona virus and the
Commissioner of the US Food and Drug
Administration says his country is very
close to the peak of its coronavirus
case load he is hopeful that
restrictions can be eased by the 1st of
May in Spain the number of deaths rose
in the past 24 hours by more than a
hundred to 619 but new infections
declined during the same period
South Korea reported 32 additional cases
in the past day continuing a downward
trend in infections there and Russia
meanwhile has confirmed more than 2,000
new cases its biggest daily increase
since the outbreak began